[Music]
this morning in this memorial day
weekend the long search to find answers
about an often forgotten part of world
war ii
tens of thousands of u.s soldiers died
on so-called hell ships
japanese merchant vessels turned into
prison ships for transporting u.s and
allied prisoners of war
to slave labor camps many were never
found or properly identified
leaving anguished families searching for
answers even today more than
75 years later as we learn for some
answers may finally be coming
dateline pearl harbor december 7th 1941.
just hours after japanese airplanes bomb
pearl harbor in hawaii
pulling the united states into world war
ii an
air and ground campaign against u.s
forces was launched
in the philippines evacuated by its
defenders
manila was the invaders for the taking
thousands of americans stationed in the
philippines
were thrust into combat the u.s troops
days from the constant pounding of
japanese bombs and shells
knew that the end had come fighting
against an overwhelming force
u.s general jonathan wainwright was
forced to surrender
some ten thousand prisoners were taken
in the fall of corregidor
three thousand of them were civilians
the infamous death march would later
claim many of them
one of the many men sent into a tortuous
march
was army doctor clarence white white had
been stationed in the philippines with
his family
his wife and daughter were evacuated
before fighting started
it was the last time they saw him nancy
craig
is his daughter you didn't really know
your dad because you were so young
and your mom never talked about this my
mom did not talk
i would ask what kind of a man was my
dad
and she would say he was a very good man
after enduring three years of starvation
and horrific conditions in a japanese
prisoner of war camp
clarence white was loaded aboard a
civilian merchant vessel
a so-called hell ship packed with
hundreds of other allied prisoners
bound for slave labor camps for three
days allied planes attacked their
targets
not a single japanese ship escaped
undamaged
at the same time the u.s was involved in
an air campaign against
merchant vessels suspected of carrying
supplies for the japanese
unaware these ships were also carrying
captured americans
white's ship the oriuku meru was hit but
he survived
he was moved to a second hell ship the
inurumaru
that was also bombed the 300 men that
died
on the an armoreroo were placed into
cargo nets
and dumped into a mass grave on formosa
that was all that we knew
the limited amount nancy craig knows
about what happened to her dad
is from stories told by others who were
captured
men like dan crowley a member of the
army air corps
crowley was taken prisoner when the
philippines fell to the japanese in may
1942
he was held for three and a half years
what was the worst part about being on
the hell ship on the hell [ __ ] the worst
part was drinking the other fellas
human waste because if you were down the
lower
wooden platform it's all flowing down on
you
crowley made it back and today is
celebrating
his 99th birthday are there times when
you wonder how you survived
oh no i knew i was going to survive and
get home and kick the rashes
for the brutal nasty things they did to
people
but a lot of people didn't survive
correct
and they were unfortunate that's why
we're here
this weekend to remember them by the
time the war ended an estimated
21 thousand men died on hell ships
some of the remains were later taken to
hawaii and placed in 20 plots
at the national memorial cemetery of the
pacific
also called the punch bowl 20 unknowns
22 unknowns 22 unknowns right
just looking at the number of unknowns
still here you can tell how many
mysteries are still yet to be solved
thousands thousands of mysteries yet to
be solved
johnny webb has been working to identify
missing and unidentified u.s servicemen
for more than 40 years he's a deputy
director at the defense
pow mia accounting agency which has
forensic facilities here in hawaii
this is the largest forensic skeletal
laboratory in the world yes that's
correct
webb and his team are using new dna
technologies
to make identifications that for decades
were never possible
what we can do now with a single tooth
we can make identification from a small
bone fragment
we can make an identification uh using
the dna
i think hell ships are is still
something that a lot of
people are not familiar with i would
agree with that
there's not a lot about hell ships it's
not you know it's not a famous battle
that was fought during world war
ii many families or many of the american
public
are not aware of the hell ships and what
they represent
these mysteries are now 75 years old so
for you
this is a race against time we know it's
a challenge
but we definitely believe that with
these resources
we can we can get there
dr camilla rogers is a disinterment
specialist at the lab
when we know that there are family
members out there
that don't have the answers they are
looking for
whose loved ones died there were wives
who died
wondering where their husbands were
there were fathers who died
wondering where their what their sons
were
some of them died grieved themselves to
death
and this grief was passed on from
generation to generation
and so if i
can play if we as an organization can
play that integral part
of finding their loved ones
it is an honor to do that
and it is our duty to do that for those
individuals for those men who gave their
lives
as the extraordinary work at joint base
pearl harbor continues
other parts of hell ship history are
also getting a second look
number one p.o.w that's true
i'll accept that okay dan crowley
never properly recognized for his
sacrifice
was finally honored at this ceremony in
january
your military records properly reflect
your time spent as a pow
and you are authorized to wear the
enclosed prisoner of war metal
congratulations on your pow medal oh
that
long time totally took about 80 years
off
as for clarence white one account says
he died on the deck of that second hell
ship when it was bombed
it's believed his remains may be among
those buried at the punch bowl
but no identification has ever been made
79 years after she last saw him
nancy craig is still looking for answers
i don't talk about closure i talk about
connections
an official identification would be a
connection and it would be definitely a
connection
yes and i would uh
love to have that to um
bring it to riverside national cemetery
where my mother is buried
oh yes
we certainly hope nancy makes that
connection one of the issues here is
that they need to get dna
from 60 more than 60 percent of possible
candidates
to clear the disinterment to move this
it takes years and years to get all this
done um but they're trying as hard as
they can i love that she looks at it
as a connection she doesn't say i'm not
yeah it's not closure for me it's
connected connection
yeah it's important work and happy
birthday to dan crowley
99 years old today what a guy that is
awesome he was fantastic
so glad to hear happy birthday peace